THE GEORGIA CRIMINAL
INVESTIGATION INTO DONALD
TRUMP'S EFRTS TO OVERTURN THE
20 ELECTION PICKING UP SOME
SPEED.
ALL 16 OF THE, QUOTE, FAKE
ELECTORS PART, OF THE PLAN TO
REPLACE JOE BIDEN'S LEGITIMATE
ELECTORS WITH TRUMP ELECTORS --
WE ARE TOLD TODAY THAT THEY ARE
NOW PART OF THE CRIMINAL PROBE.
JOINING ME NOW IS STACEY ABRAMS,
A DEMOCRATIC CANDIDATE FOR
GEORGIA GOVERNOR.
THANK YOU, STACEY ABRAMS, FOR
JOINING US.
I APPRECIATE IT.
>> THANK YOU.
>> THIS ALLEGED PLOT TO
OVERTURN THE ELECTION IN
GEORGIA SEEMS TO KEEP GETTING
BIGGER AND CLOSER TO THE FORMER
PRESIDENT.
NEVER A DULL MOMENT WHEN IT
COMES TO GEORGIA POLITICS.
YOU GUYS YOU ALWAYS SEEM IN THE
SPOTLIGHT.
WHY IS IT SO SIGNIFICANT THAT
THIS IS GOING DOWN IN YOUR
STATE?
>> BECAUSE THIS IS A STATE THAT
IS HAS UNFORTUNATELY A VERY
LONG AND RECENT HISTORY OF
VOTER SUPPRESSION AND OF VOTER
INTIMIDATION AND CHALLENGES IN
OUR SYSTEM.
I KNOW THAT ONE OF THE PEOPLE
ON THAT LIST IS THE REPUBLICAN
NOMINEE FOR LIEUTENANT
GOVERNOR.
AND THAT OUR CURRENT GOVERNOR
HAS SAID HE IS PROUD TO HAVE
HIM AS A RUNNING MATE.
HE IS PROOF OF THE FACT THAT,
IN GEORGIA, WHETHER YOU ARE THE
GOVERNOR WHO JUST HAPPENED NOT
TO COMMIT TREASON, OR THE
LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR WHO MAY
HAVE PARTICIPATED IN THE
SEDITIOUS ACT, THAT EITHER OF
THEM ARE POOR REPRESENTATION OF
WHAT DEMOCRACY SHOULD BE IN THE
STATE OF GEORGIA OR IN THE
UNITED STATES.
>> SO, YOU MENTIONED THE
GOVERNOR, YOU WILL BE RUNNING
AGAINST HIM, THE PRESIDENT, I
WANT TO TALK ABOUT THAT IN THE
CONTEXT OF THE CURRENT
PRESIDENT --
JOE BIDEN'S APPROVAL RATING OF
DROPPING TO THE LOWEST LEVEL IT
HAS EVER BEEN.
ONLY 38% OF PEOPLE APPROVING OF
THE JOB.
--
AS YOU ARE AWARE OF.
BUT THESE NUMBERS DON'T LOOK
GOOD, STACEY.
IF VOTERS AREN'T HAPPY WITH THE
HEAD OF THE PARTY, THAT WILL
HAVE AN IMPACT ON DEMOCRATS IN
RACES ACROSS THE COUNTRY,
INCLUDING YOU IN YOUR
GOVERNOR'S RACE.
>> WE UNDERSTAND THAT THE
NATIONAL CHALLENGES ARE REAL,
THAT THE IMPACT OF INFLATION,
THAT THE RISING COSTS ARE
ABSOLUTELY DEVASTATING TO
FAMILIES.
BUT WE ALSO KNOW THAT THE
GOVERNOR HAS THE ABILITY TO DO
SOMETHING ABOUT IT.
UNFORTUNATELY, THIS GOVERNOR
HAS REFUSED TO ACT.
HE IS SITTING ON MORE THAN $547
MILLION THAT COULD HELP
FAMILIES STAY IN THEIR HOMES.
INSTEAD THEY ARE FACING
EVICTIONS AT A RECORD RATE.
HE COULD DO SOMETHING ON THE
RECORD ISSUE OF GUN VIOLENCE.
AND YET HE WEAKENED GUN LAWS TO
PUT MORE HANDS WEAPONS IN THE
HANDS OF CRIMINALS AND
DANGEROUS PEOPLE.
HE COULD ADDRESS THE NEEDS OF
WOMEN BY EXPANDING ACCESS TO
HEALTH CARE.
INSTEAD OF EXPANDING MEDICAID,
WHICH WOULD LOWER COST NOT ONLY
FOR LOWER INCOME FAMILIES COST
ACROSS THE BOARD, HE HAS SIGNED
INTO LAW THE MOST EXTREME AND
DANGEROUS ABORTION LAW IN THE
STATE'S HISTORY, MAKING IT
DANGEROUS FOR WOMEN TO EVEN
CONTEMPLATE GETTING PREGNANT.
HE HAS MADE IT HARDER TO BE A
GEORGIAN, HARDER TO SURVIVE
HERE.
AND WHILE THE NATIONAL
HEADWINDS MAY BE REAL, WE KNOW
THAT THE PAIN AND THE TRAUMA
AND THE DANGER IN GEORGIA IF
BRIAN KEMP REMAINS GOVERNOR IS
ALSO REAL.
>> THE QUESTION WAS ABOUT BIDEN,
THOUGH, AND WHETHER BIDEN
IMPACTS YOU IN YOUR AND YOUR
RACE.
>> AND MY POINT IS THIS --
THAT WHILE WE LIVE IN A NATION
WHERE THE PRESIDENT IS DOING
HIS BEST TO CONFRONT ECONOMIC
CHALLENGES THAT ARE HAPPENING
AROUND THE WORLD, WE HAVE A
GOVERNOR WHO HAS THE VERY REAL
TOOLS IN HIS HAND, PROVIDED BY
DEMOCRATS, TO ACTUALLY STAVE
OFF THE CHALLENGES.
HE HAS THE ABILITY TO TAKE
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS PROVIDED TO
THE STATE BY PRESIDENT BIDEN,
BY SENATOR RAPHAEL WARNOCK AND
SENATOR JON OSSOFF.
AND INSTEAD HE IS REFUSING TO
DEPLOY THOSE RESOURCES.
HE IS REFUSING TO EXPAND
MEDICAID.
HE IS REFUSING TO ACKNOWLEDGE
THE HOUSING CRISIS.
AND SO IT'S VERY IMPORTANT THAT
WE RECOGNIZE THAT THE
GOVERNOR'S RACES MATTER BECAUSE
GOVERNORS HAVE THE ABILITY TO
RESPOND LOCALLY AND DIRECTLY TO
THE NEEDS OF THE PEOPLE.
AND BRIAN KEMP IS REFUSING TO
DO THAT JOB BECAUSE HE DOESN'T
CARE OR BECAUSE HE IS UNWILLING
TO DO HIS JOB.
>> BUT DOESN'T SEEM TO BE
HELPING HIM IN GEORGIA?
I MEAN, MAYBE THAT'S WHERE
GEORGIANS ARE.
I'M JUST WONDERING.
BECAUSE OTHERWISE HE WOULDN'T
BE DOING IT IF HE DIDN'T THINK
IT WAS BENEFICIAL.
AND THE POLLS ARE SHOWING THAT
HE IS DOING OKAY.
>> THE POLLS HAVE US IN A
PRETTY DEAD HEAT.
AND THE REALITY IS, I HAVE BEEN
TRAVELING THE STATE.
I JUST GOT BACK FROM VISITING
BACONTON AND ALBANY.
AND TIFTON, GEORGIA AND EVERY
SINGLE PLACE I HEAR FROM
FAMILIES WHO ARE IN PAIN AND I
WONDER WHY THE GOVERNOR WON'T
STEP OUT AND HELP THEM WITH
THEIR HOUSING CRISIS.
THEY WANT TO KNOW WHY HE WON'T
EXPAND MEDICAID, WHEN HEALTH
CARE COSTS ARE REAL.
WHEN PART OF WHAT IS HAPPENING
WITH INFLATION IS THAT THE COST
OF EVERYTHING IS GOING UP.
AND WHEN YOU HAVE TO DECIDE
BETWEEN PUTTING FOOD ON YOUR
TABLE OR PUTTING MEDICINE IN
YOUR BODY, THAT IS THE WRONG
CHOICE YOU HAVE TO MAKE AND
GEORGIANS ARE BEING FORCED TO
MAKE THOSE CHOICES, DESPITE
HAVING THE RESOURCES.
GEORGIA HAS THE ABILITY --
THE GOVERNOR HAS THE ABILITY --
TO SOLVE THESE PROBLEMS.
AND HE IS REFUSING TO.
BUT HE IS COUNTING ON PEOPLE
ONLY PAYING ATTENTION TO WHAT
HE HAS DONE.
HE IS REFUSING TO OFFER A
SINGLE SENSE OF WHAT HE IS
GOING TO DO TO TACKLE THIS
CRISIS.
AND THAT IS WHY I'M GOING TO
RUN WIN THE RACE FOR GOVERNOR.
>> YOU'VE GOT KEY SENATE RACE
HAPPENING DOWN THERE.
WHAT WOULD IT MEAN TO GEORGIA
AND OF THE COUNTRY TO HAVE A
CENTER HERSCHEL WALKER INSTEAD
OF A SENATOR RAPHAEL WARNOCK?
>> WE BEGIN BY HAVING A SENATOR
WHO HAS MISLED THE PUBLIC,
MISLED THE PARTY, AND MISLED
THE PEOPLE OF GEORGIA.
AS OPPOSED TO SENATOR WARNOCK,
WHO HAS DONE EVERYTHING HE CAN
TO SERVE OUR COMMUNITIES.
HE BROUGHT THE RESOURCES TO THE
STATE THAT BRIAN KEMP IS
CURRENTLY TAKING CREDIT FOR
ADVANTAGE OF.
HE HAS BEEN A CHAMPION FOR
ALLOWING CROFT'S --
WHETHER IT IS PRESCRIPTION
DRUGS OR MAKING SURE WE HAVE
GAS PRICES THAT ARE LOWER --
I STAND IN LOCKSTEP WITH
SENATOR RAPHAEL WARNOCK BECAUSE
WE BELIEVE THAT WE CAN SERVE
GEORGIA.
LET'S BE CLEAR, DON.
YOU CAN EITHER HAVE TRICKLE
DOWN ECONOMICS OR AN ECONOMIC
POLICY THAT LIFTS ALL BOATS.
UNFORTUNATELY, WHETHER IT IS
HERSCHEL WALKER OR BRIAN KEMP,
THEY ONLY SERVE THOSE WHO
BENEFIT THEMSELVES.
THEY HAVE NO PROVEN ENGAGEMENT
IN COMMUNITIES THAT NEED THEIR
HELP, INCLUDING A MIDDLE CLASS
THAT IS STRUGGLING JUST AS HARD
TO STAY WHERE THEY ARE.
RAPHAEL WARNOCK IS DOING THAT
WORK.
I, AS AN INDEPENDENT AND
PRIVATE CITIZEN, HAVE BEEN
DOING THAT WORK.
BUT UNFORTUNATELY, THE
REPUBLICAN TICKET HAS NO
INTEREST IN DOING THE WORK FOR
THE PEOPLE OF GEORGIA.
>> A SIMILAR QUESTION, AS I
ASKED YOU BEFORE --
I MEAN, HERSCHEL WALKER IS,
DESPITE ALL THE MISSTEPS,
DESPITE ALL THE LIES THAT HE
HAS BEEN CAUGHT IN, THE FACTS
THAT PROVE HE HAS NEVER WORKED
IN LAW ENFORCEMENT AND SO ON
AND SO FORTH --
HE IS STILL DOING OKAY IN THE
POLLS.
WHAT DOES THAT SAY ABOUT WHERE
GEORGIANS ARE IN THIS MOMENT,
THAT SOMEONE LIKE HERSCHEL
WALKER CAN STILL BE DOING WELL
DESPITE ALL OF THE HEADWINDS OR
ALL OF THE CONTROVERSY HE HAS
CREATED?
>> GEORGIA IS A DIVIDED STATE.
WE ARE PURPLE FOR A REASON.
WE ARE HALF DEMOCRATIC, HALF
REPUBLICAN.
MY RACE IN 2018 WAS THE
DIFFERENCE OF 1.4%.
THE VICTORY THAT RAPHAEL
WARNOCK HAD A YEAR AND A HALF
LATER --
I'M SORRY, FOUR YEARS LATER --
THAT VICTORY WAS 100,000 VOTES
THIS IS A VERY NARROW MARGIN
STATE AND BECAUSE OF THAT EVERY
VOTE COUNTS.
AND THAT GOES BACK TO THE
ORIGINAL POINT.
WE HAVE TO HAVE LEADERS WHO
BELIEVE IN DEMOCRACY AND
BELIEVE IN EVERY VOTER HAS THE
RIGHT TO BE HEARD.
BRIAN KEMP DOES NOT BELIEVE
THAT.
PRIOR TO HIS ONE DAY OF GRACE,
THE FACT THAT HE IS GETTING
CREDIT FOR NOT COMMITTING
TREASON, HE BUILT A REPUTATION
AS SOMEONE WHO NOT ONLY SPAWNED
AND --
SUPPRESSION.
HE CELEBRATED IT.
HE SAID DURING HIS REPUBLICAN
PRIMARY THAT HE PASSED ESPY 202
BECAUSE HE DIDN'T LIKE THE
RESULTS OF THE FEDERAL ELECTION
IN 2020 AND 2021.
WE WIN THESE ELECTIONS WHEN
PEOPLE KNOW WHO WE ARE RUNNING
AGAINST.
AND BECAUSE THE STATE IS
DIVIDED, EVERY VOTE IS GOING TO
COUNT.
RAPHAEL WARNOCK ARE GOING TO
WORK HARD, UP AND DOWN THE
TICKET, TO MAKE SURE WE TURN
OUT EVERY SINGLE VOTER, TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE HAVE A VOTER
GEORGIA MOVING FORWARD.
>> STACEY ABRAMS, THANKS FOR
APPEARING.
>> THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME.
>> AND I WANT TO KNOW THAT WE
DID INVITE STACEY ABRAMS
OPPONENT GOVERNOR KEMP ON THE
SHOW AND HE IS WELCOME TO JOIN
US ON THIS BROADCAST ANYTIME WE